Here's our numerator and here's our denominator. Fantastic algebra skills if you
got these two correct. This one was really tough, so don't worry if you didn't
get it right on your first try or even at all. Let's see how we can multiply by
the LCD and simplify. We know we're going to multiply by the LCD divided by the
LCD. When we do that, we really just distribute this to each term in our complex
fraction. This gives us this expression. Now, this is pretty hideous. So let's
clean it up. We know x plus 2 divided by x plus 2 equals 1. So we're left with 3
times x squared for our first term. This next multiplication was a little
tricky. We have x squared divided by x. We can only cancel 1x from this power
and this denominator. This means we have to drop the squared power down to a 1.
And we're left with 4 times 1x times x plus 2. I want to make sure I have it
negative 4 times 1x. So I have negative 4x. Then I had times x plus 2 here. This
denominator is a little bit more simple. These factors simplify to 1 and these
factors also simplify to 1. So, we're left with 2 times x squared for the first
term of our denominator and 1 times x plus 2 or just x plus 2 for the second
term of our denominator. I need to multiply or distribute this negative 4x to
the quantity x plus 2. This gives me a new numerator. For the denominator, I
don't multiply. I really add, since we have addition between these two terms.
Since there aren't any like terms here, I just list out each term, 2x squared
plus x plus 2. And to finish out we just simply combine the like terms in our
numerator. 3x squared minus 4x squared is negative x squared. So here's our
final rational expression.